it has been a tense 10 days for european
leaders but today the news came that
russia has resumed gas deliveries to the
continent via its biggest pipeline
nordstream one
the pipeline was shut down for 10 days
for scheduled maintenance
and many feared moscow would not resume
supplies because of tensions over its
invasion of ukraine
but despite the fact that the gas is
flowing again it is expected to fall
short of capacity on the outlook is
uncertain
and we have team coverage of this
development we are joined by
correspondent benjamin alvarez gruber
who is in lumen where the north stream 1
gas pipeline enters germany and rob
watts from dw business is with us here
in the studio benjamin i'd like to begin
with you there in the field gas has
started flowing again as we've heard is
this the sigh of relief that europe has
been hoping for
it's a sigh of relief at least for now
but for the german government russia is
very unreliable the german economy
minister and vice chancellor has
repeatedly said that what russia is
doing is using technical issues to take
political decisions you mentioned it
saying that russia is using
energy
energy this crisis f4 they for an
opportunity also for them so for now it
is a sigh of relief numbers could reach
around 40 of the capacity so quite
similar to the numbers that we had
before this annual maintenance it
happens every year but the situation is
very dynamic and could change in weeks
or in months
okay uh rob economically at this point
at this stage how dependent is europe on
russian gas well even now it's still
very dependent on russian gas the big
realization the dawning realization as
soon as russian troops set foot in
ukraine for the eu was that it was too
dependent on russia for its energy it
was getting 40 of its gas that's the eu
as a whole certain countries were
getting much more than that germany was
getting you know 55 of its gas from
russia and the likes of hungary for
example getting 85 percent so that is
why we've had over the past few months
leaders from the eu leaders from germany
leaders from the european commission
traveling around particularly in the
middle east trying to secure more
supplies just this week we got a new
deal between the european union and
azerbaijan which will see azerbaijan
doubling uh its gas supplies to the eu
but that'll still only be a you know a
drop in the water compared with the
amount of gas that the eu continues to
get from russia and it's still a an
enormous
reliance that it has on russia for that
and we've had the imf this week
submitting some research that it's done
to the eu saying look
if you do not find a way to replace
russian gas this year and you go into
the winter without russian gas should
russia decide that it doesn't want to
supply it anymore then your economies
are going to take a hit it looks at
germany and it says you know it could be
a three percent drop in gdp for germany
for hungary which i already mentioned it
could be a six percent drop in gdp
because we could be looking at depending
on the country's reliance between them
on russian gas of shortfalls of up to
forty percent of the gas that they need
to get through the winter okay so quite
a lot um benjamin given that given what
rob has just said what are heavily
reliant countries for example like
germany doing right now to prepare for
the fact that russia could choose
perhaps sometime in the future to cut
off gas
they're searching for other partners and
what rob just mentioned there we had the
economy minister traveling around he was
in the czech republic he was in austria
saying that european solidarity is very
important to tackle this problem he was
also in qatar so the alternatives the
germany now has for the so-called liquid
natural gas to have new lng terminals it
would be here in northern germany as
well they could then deliver this gas
either from qatar or also from the
united states of america to search for
new energy partnerships there's also a
french energy giant that said that by
december of this year it could have an
operating lng terminal to have
alternatives to the russian gas that
germany is trying to cut as much as
possible
russia of course profits significantly
um from supplying gas to europe rob how
has that changed since the war in
ukraine well it's as you say an enormous
source of income and and fueling the war
machine of russia so the eu has been
trying to reduce its usage and it's done
that by about a quarter germany's gone
from getting 55 of its gas to 35 percent
of its gas from russia and part of the
reason for doing that was to choke off
the war machine as well as to reduce the
reliance but the problem is that by
doing that and also the fact that uh you
know
gas prices have been rising enormously
russia's actually probably making more
money than it was before the war from
oil and gas imports in fact there was
some research last week that suggested
is making something like 93 billion it's
made something like 93 billion euros
since the start of the war from fossil
fuels around a quarter of that is from
natural gas and the eu remains its
biggest partner so you can argue whether
or not these reductions in usage of
russian gas are actually taking effect
and then you can look at what russia's
been doing over the last month and you
can say it clearly thinks it has the
financial headroom to deliberately be
cutting the amount of gas that it is
selling to the eu all right well um rob
watts from dw business putting it into
context for us and benjamin alvarez
gruber joining us from lubin with the
view from the ground thank you so much
to both of you